&gt;&gt; Our second option, however, is to solve this just algebraically. We've solved
quadratic equations before, when we're trying to find x intercepts. The only
difference between those situations, and this one, is that we have a 3 over
here. Remember that a quadratic equation, is anything that can be written in the
form Ax squared plus Bx plus C equals 0. The issue here, is that we don't have
0, on this side of the equation, so let's make it happen. How do we do that? You
know you just subtract 3 from both sides, that gives us X squared plus 8x plus
twelve equals 0. Since you know how to solve this using factoring, I'd like you
to tell me the possible solutions for X. In the event that you find X can take
on multiple values to make this equation true, please just write all those
values in this box but separate them with commas.